So you, uh, become a musician. Uh,
you have like an international trip. Um,
you have this arc that spans years. How did,
when was the first time you started realizing, wait a minute, like,
I'm not sure how fully I believe these things or that this is wrong or that
there is something, uh,
very dark and hateful that I may not want to continue to lead.
W was there a particular moment or revelation or relationship?
I think I had doubts from the time I was 14 years old and I guy came up to me in
that alley every day until the day I left eight years later. Um, but you know,
there certainly were some moments that were kind of like trajectory changers.
Absolutely. Um, uh, 19 years old, I got married, uh, to, you know,
another girl, a girl who was 19 years old,
we had a child and then two years later we had another child.
So by the time I was 21,
I had two kids and I was a dad and a husband that helped change me because my
wife wasn't involved in the movement. And when I was home,
I didn't want to introduce my family to that. She knew, uh, and she, you know,
begrudgingly, you know, went along with it. Um,
but I also was a different person at home. Uh,
so I had kind of a replacement identity, community and purpose. Uh,
and that was a massive help. Um, also around 1995,
just before I left the movement, um,
because I was trying to compromise with my wife at the time.
She didn't want me on the streets. I decided, uh, to open a record shop, um,
to try and make myself more legitimate. Uh,
but I was selling racist music that I was importing music that I was making. Uh,
and, um, but I was also selling hip hop and punk rock and, you know,
black metal and stuff like that. And it was called chaos records. Uh,
so it wasn't, it was pretty evident that we were intent on causing chaos. Um,
but the people I met there, they knew who, who I was.
They knew what I was selling. And they were, you know, customers who were, uh,
black or Brown or Jewish or gay. And they treated me like a human being. And,
and although it wasn't their responsibility to do that. And, and, uh, uh,
I'm very grateful that they did though. They sh you know, they,
they didn't have to do that. Um, that helped change me.
I received compassion from people I didn't even deserve it from,
and that was super powerful. You know, it was 75% of my revenue.
It was pre-internet.
So people were coming in from all over the country from Canada to buy.
And I was one of the only stores in America that was sewing, that kind of music.
So.
75% Of your record store revenue was from the white power,
racist music, like racist music. Wow. Myself, that,
that you had like a fairly normal record store. And then there were like some,
some people who were getting the stuff like on the, you know,
the fly on the side,
but it sounds like that was most of the revenue that's insane.
Well, it was probably only 10% of my inventory.
I didn't even keep it out in the, you know, in the shelves.
I kept all the regular stuff out into the shelves,
but still the racist music was seventy-five percent of my revenue,
even though it was only 10% of my inventory.
Uh, yeah. So that was the business then. I mean,
clearly it's not like a normal record store with like a, you know,
like a sideline. I mean, it was essentially, I hate music.
No, it was, it was a hate music store. But then when I pulled that,
cause like became embarrassed to sell it because of these new people I was
becoming friendly with. Uh,
I pulled that music and of course I had to close the store because I couldn't
even keep the doors open anymore.
Yeah. So that, that might've been the big decision. Then when you, like,
if you make the decision to, to snuff out your business, I mean,
you have to know that's happening. Um.
My wife also left me. She left me at that same time.
I hit rock bottom is what happened. I just closed the store. My wife left me,
took the kids. Um,
and I used that opportunity in a very sneaky and cowardly way to
walk away from the movement. I didn't denounce it. Uh, I didn't tell, you know,
I told my buddies I'll be back. I just need to go work on my life.
Be back in a few months, I was never planning on going back. Uh,
it took me about five years before I kind of denounced it and faced my past
head-on I didn't, I didn't really start doing that until, you know,
1999 or 2000, because I was running from,
I was really trying to run from who I was as fast as I could, um,
until I realized it was killing me to do that.
So, in your case, uh, you went to college, I want to say, um, is that right?
Correct. Yeah. Um, I left the movement 96,
took me a couple of years to really figure out who I was.
I got kind of depressed. And then in 99, um, a friend of mine,
one of the few friends I had at the time, uh,
encouraged me to go apply for a job at IBM. And I thought she was crazy.
You know, here I was the sec skinhead full of tattoos. I hadn't,
I'd been kicked out of like six high schools, one of them twice.
I didn't go to college. I didn't even own a computer at the time.
Andrew she's like, yeah, go apply at IBM to, you know,
a new position that they offered, like, okay, sure.
And I went in and it was an entry-level position. Uh, it was, uh, setting up,
um, and, uh, kind of re uh,
re-imaging all the computers that like a corporation would, uh, buy at once.
So it'd be like 400 computers and we'd spend a month, you know, setting that up.
And my first job was to install all the hundreds of computers that my old
high school,
the one I had gotten kicked out of twice and they offered me the job and I took
it. It was super entry level. Uh,
and I was terrified because even though they had no idea about my past,
the first day of my first job out of the movement was to go set up the
computers at my old high school.
And I thought I was going to get fired and they, you know, destroy my life. Um,
and I went, I was terrified and, uh, you know,
moral of the story, IBM eventually sent me to S to go to college.
But moral of the story was I met the man there that day on my
first day at work, who was the old security guard at my old high school,
black man who I, whose life I had made hell.
And he was the one who changed my trajectory. He's the one who, you know,
I didn't what to say to him when I came across him in the hallway. I said,
I'm sorry. Uh, his name's John Holmes. I said, I'm sorry, Mr. Holmes.
And he looked at me kind of scared because I had made his life hell when I had
gone to that school. And he said, you know, sorry, makes you feel good.
It doesn't do a whole lot for me. Uh, so I think, you know,
you need to repair the damage you've done. And he embraced me.
This was a man I'd heard a black guy who, you know,
in my heyday was I made his life hell. Uh, and he embraced me and he said,
I, you know, I believe in you. And, and I think you need to tell your story.
And that was in 1999.
And I started telling my story in roughly January of 2000,
20 years ago changed my life. You saved my life. I don't know.
That I would have made it without him.
Well, I'd say extraordinarily compassionate of him, you know,
like we all like to hope that we might react similarly to someone who tormented
us, but, um, most of us don't have that in us. I don't think. Um,
so you're at IBM at this role. And then they say, you know what?
You could use some, some studies. And so they ended up, um,
helping you go to DePaul. Is that right?
Yeah. So I started out at this just like computer installer,
and then I worked my way up to an assistant researcher or assistant project
manager. And then I became an assistant researcher. And then, uh,
I got hired on to IBM. Full-time, uh,
started to lead a team in their SMB and our small,
medium business division when the internet was just picking up steam. Uh, and,
uh, through the work that I done had started like over 12 quarters, um,
like had developed leads that were like a quarter of a billion dollar.
So at that point, IBM was, was very happy with, with my work. I had, uh,
developed kind of this pioneering research team there, um,
in the sales department. So they were like, yeah, you know, we should really,
you need a degree. And I was like, yeah, I would agree with that.
So I went and I got my degree as an adult, uh,
in international relations and international business. Uh, and, uh,
I spent almost, I think, seven years or almost eight years at IBM. Uh,
and I got my degree from DePaul during that time too.
And I'm really grateful for that.
Wow. What an art.
Then. So that takes you through a particular period.
And are you in touch with your, um, ex wife and kids at that time?
Um, yeah, uh, yeah.
Yeah. I never lost touch with, with my ex-wife and my kids, you know,
it was difficult with my ex-wife when we went through the divorce,
but I always wanted to be a good dad.
So I always always had the kids every weekend, you know,
Friday to Monday as they were growing up.
So I never lost that connection with them. And in fact,
they're 28 and 26 years old. They're not little boys anymore. Uh, and, uh,
yeah, so, um, they're doing great and they saved my life too. I mean,
it hadn't been for them to really challenge me and for me to have,
to be honest with them about who I was.
Um, I don't know that I would've made it this far. So then.
In 2000 you started telling your story you're still working for IBM. Um,
how did that transition look? No, eventually you wound up writing these books,
uh, starting these organizations in media, um, trying to get the word out.
Um, w w was that a, a big step I'm sure.
The first time you started telling people openly about your past,
that must have been very, very difficult.
Yeah. I mean, it really took, I told very, very few people,
like from 2000 to 2003, it was, you know,
I started to talk to family and people that I knew, my wife,
who I've been married to now for, for, you know,
15 years have known for almost 18 or 19 years, um,
who also worked at IBM at the time. It wasn't until 2003.
When I went to DePaul that I really started to tell my story. And then, uh,
in 2004, when my brother was murdered, uh,
that's when I really started to do the work that I'm doing now,
when I started to focus on trying to help people disengage from hate groups,
because I realized at that point that I hadn't,
that I could've been a better big brother to him. Uh,
and that now I could probably try and do that with other people that I didn't
know that also needed kind of a, you know, a guiding voice, so to speak.
Well, we're certainly glad that you did, and you ended up writing a memoir, um,
that that was published, uh, in multiple countries, uh,
and it'd become, uh, an incredible figure.
Thank you. Thank you for listening in. I hope you enjoyed this conversation.
If you did, please do subscribe to yang,
speaks and click on notifications so we can let you know every time we have a
new episode.